and then K9 showed up. The K7 community, I think, I don't know really what the state of it is. So now there's K7, which at one point had a big community around it, K4, which is behind Q. But a community that ended because this guy unilaterally decided,
然后 K9 就出现了。K7 社区，我想，我其实也不知道它的现状到底是怎样的。所以现在有了 K7，它曾经拥有一个庞大的社区；还有 K4，它是 Q 的幕后语言。但这个社区最终走向了解散，因为这个人单方面决定，
oh no, this thing that you're using, I'm going to delete it and build a better one? Yes. This is an interesting software governance model. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 96 recorded on September 19th, 2022. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about the K programming language. Dear listener, it is September 19th, 2022. The last time we recorded was August 15th, 2022. It's been over a month. Much has happened in the last month. I almost died.
“哦不，你们正在用的这个东西，我要把它删掉然后造一个更好的？”是的。这是一个很有意思的软件治理模式。欢迎来到第 96 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2022 年 9 月 19 日。我是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起聊聊 K 编程语言。亲爱的听众朋友，今天是 2022 年 9 月 19 日。我们上次录音还是在 2022 年 8 月 15 日。已经过去了一个多月。过去的一个月里发生了好多事。我差点死掉。
Yes, that's right. And then we met up in New York. and then are we gonna talk about the thing i think we should do that i think we should talk about that next time because that's gonna require you're gonna need a good long period of time to to troll me oh okay yeah so are we allowed to are we it's okay my girlfriend is going through there's going to be some background noise but you know what that's part of the show you get oh yeah you get my real life that is um i'm talking away from the mic now so wait are we allowed to give the listener a preview at least of the thing we said we might talk about hang on hang on hang on is
是的，没错。然后我们在纽约碰面了。然后我们要聊那件事吗？我觉得我们应该聊那个，我觉得我们下次应该聊那个，因为那需要你花上一大段时间来取笑我哦好吧，所以我们能——可以吗？我女朋友正在经历——等下会有一些背景噪音，但你知道吗，这也是节目的一部分，你能——哦对，你能听到我的真实生活，那是——嗯，我现在离麦克风远了一点，所以等等，我们至少可以向听众透露一点我们刚才说可能会聊的事情吗？等等，等等，等一下，是
that the chocolate all right bring me some chocolate i'm leaving that in the episode there's that's not getting edited out you better be careful about what you say here bryce um this is poor planning on your part clearly i happen to be uninterrupted for the next 90 well okay so look look the plan was for me to go up to a different floor where I could record this. I only get one. But I'm going to be honest. I only really put on underwear today,
那个巧克力？好吧，给我拿点巧克力来。我要把这段留在节目里，这部分不会被剪掉的。布莱斯，你在这里说话最好小心点，嗯，这显然是你计划不周。我接下来 90 分钟正好不会被打扰——好吧，听着，听着，原本的计划是我去楼上的另一个房间录音，我只有一个名额。但老实说，
and I threw on this exercise shirt. I just couldn't be bothered to put on clothes to go upstairs. Sorry. Alright, we will let the listener react to that on the Twitter forums, etc. We're going to preview what we're talking about?
我今天只穿了一条内裤，然后套上了这件运动衫。我实在懒得穿好衣服上楼了。抱歉。好吧，我们会让听众在 Twitter 论坛等地方对此作出反应。我们要剧透一下我们在聊什么吗？
We'll mention the topic, because it is topical. Drunk Shakespeare. Oh, no, no, no. That's not even what I was talking about. What were you talking about? I was talking about the other thing. The listener is going to be upset if this does, if now they're going to be like, what were they talking about? The thing that I DM'd you about, and I said, oh, we're going to be talking about this. And then you replied, all right,
我们会提一下这个话题，因为它很应景。醉酒莎士比亚。哦，不，不，不。我说的根本不是那个。你在说什么？我说的是另一件事。如果现在不提，听众会生气的，他们会想：“他们在说什么呀？”就是我发私信给你的那件事，我说，哦，我们要聊这个。然后你回复说，好吧，
he's got his finger up. I'll let him finish eating his chocolate and then he can respond. Yeah, I think we should talk about the vowel programming language. And I heard about this other thing called JA jackst have you heard about that at all it's jackta j-a-k-t so what was that announced uh i mean jack has been a thing dormantly for a while that exists i believe is it in um andreas andreas clings uh serenity os i think that's where it comes from and they've been designing this i mean i should look that up yeah serenity os slash jacked a repository in the serenity os uh github um because that's an org i I'm guessing. Yeah. So, okay. To answer your question, sure, we should talk about all the new C++ successor languages. But let's talk about Val today.
他把手指竖起来了。我让他吃完巧克力，然后他再回应。对，我觉得我们应该聊聊 Val 编程语言。我还听说过另一个叫 JA jackst 的东西，你听说过吗？是 jakt，j-a-k-t。那是什么时候宣布的？——我的意思是，Jakt 已经沉寂了一段时间了，它确实存在，我相信它是在安德烈亚斯·克林（Andreas Kling）的 Serenity OS 里吧？我想就是从那里来的。他们一直在设计这个，我是说我应该查一下——对，Serenity OS 仓库下的 jakt，在 Serenity OS 的 GitHub 组织里，因为那是一个组织，我猜。所以，好吧。回答你的问题，当然，我们应该谈谈所有新的 C++ 继承者语言。但我们今天先聊聊 Val。
And then what I think we should do. Wait, wait, wait. We're not hopping in. We're just talking about what we're going to talk about we're not actually talking about anything yet so you want to talk about Val today um yeah but okay here's my broader idea
然后我觉得我们应该——等一下，等一下。我们还没切入正题呢。我们只是在讨论我们要聊什么，还没真正开始聊任何内容。所以你今天想聊 Val，嗯，不过——好吧，我有一个更宏大的想法：
we should bring Sean Baxter on the podcast to talk about Circle and all these other new languages because I know he's checked them all out and also Sean Baxter is just a fun time and we can have Sean tell us about Moby Dick I know he's checked them all out. And also, Sean Baxter is just a fun time. And we can have Sean tell us about Moby Dick, which is one of Sean's favorite subjects.
我们应该请肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）上播客来聊聊 Circle 和所有这些新语言，因为我知道他把这些都研究过了，而且肖恩·巴克斯特也很有趣，我们可以让肖恩给我们讲讲《白鲸记》，我知道这是肖恩最喜欢的题材之一。
So I think that's what we should do. All right. So we're not talking about New York today. We're not talking about how I almost died. We're not going to talk about all the exciting things that have happened recently. What we will talk about... Oh, yes, and I was going to mention, all the exciting things that have happened recently. What we will talk about. Oh, yes. And I was going to mention you got put on thin ice last time because you were eating when Kate was here.
所以我觉得我们应该这么做。好吧，所以我们今天不聊纽约，不聊我差点怎么死掉的，也不聊最近发生的所有令人兴奋的事情。我们要聊的是……哦，对，我本想提一下，你上次被罚处于危险边缘，因为凯特在的时候你在吃东西。
I'm going to bring Jason on. I'm going to test him out for a couple episodes. OK. And we're going to we're going to see, you know, do I prefer Bryce? Do I prefer Jason? And almost almost anybody would be a better co-host i'm constantly late there's constantly background noise you started off you started off great and then uh you've just become a lot more did i know you did i mean your mic quality was bad yeah but
我要把杰森请来。我要让他试录几期。好吧。我们要看看，你知道的，我是更喜欢布莱斯，还是更喜欢杰森？几乎——几乎随便什么人都比我当更好的联合主持人。我总是迟到，总是有背景噪音。你一开始——一开始表现得很好，然后，嗯，你变得越来越——我有吗？我是说你的麦克风音质很差，对，但是
uh your uh what do they call it punctualness I'm not even sure if that's the noun version of punctual. Punctuality? Who knows? But anyways, we're going to try out Jason. What happened though? I can't remember. You said something that made me think of this. One thing we do have to mention is that on Reddit a few days ago now, someone asked the question, are there any good podcasts about C++? Oh, this is too meta. This is too meta. And a bunch of people, oh, yeah, that's what happened is that you said something about, oh, you know, it's just the way our podcast operates. And then made me think about a few of the comments.
嗯，你的——他们叫什么来着？守时性？我甚至不确定这是“守时”的名词形式。守时（Punctuality）？谁知道呢。不管怎样，我们要试试杰森。不过刚才是怎么回事？我想不起来了。你说了句话让我想起了这个。我们必须提到的一件事是，就在几天前的 Reddit 上，有人问了这样一个问题：有没有什么好的 C++ 播客？哦，这太元了。这太元了。然后有一群人——哦，对了，发生的事情是，你说了句类似“哦，你知道的，这就是我们播客的运作方式”，然后让我想起了其中的一些评论。
So I replied, but I'll read my reply after I scan. So the top comment was by Jake Arkenstall. I hope they don't mind that we're calling out their username on Reddit. And says, for chatty, ADSP is great. There's a lot off-topic, casual content, but that's what podcasts usually are. Thanks, Jake. That's very kind what podcasts usually are. Thanks, Jake. That's very kind of you to say.
所以我回复了，但我扫一眼之后再读我的回复。最上面的评论是杰克·阿肯斯托尔（Jake Arkenstall）发的。希望他们不介意我们在 Reddit 上直接念出他们的用户名。评论说：对于喜欢唠嗑的人来说，ADSP 很棒。有很多跑题的、随意的闲聊，但播客通常不就是这样吗？谢谢杰克。你这么说真是太好了。
That was generous. Yeah. Then someone else, JV Apen, they said about us, and I thought this was the best like six or seven words summary, maybe other than a discussion with Sean Parent, which has become less true seeing as we haven't had him on in 20 episodes or so. ADSP the podcast, and then in parentheses, the explanation of us. Chaos and chatting with sprinkles of information. I thought that
这太慷慨了。是的。然后另一个人，JV Apen，他们对我们的评价是——我觉得这是对我们最好的一句六七个字的总结，或许除了跟肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）的那次讨论外，不过鉴于我们已经有 20 来期没邀请过他了，这话现在没那么准确了。ADSP 播客——然后在括号里是对我们的解释：混乱的闲聊，夹杂着些许知识。我觉得这个
was fantastic. I might add that to the website as the byline. Chaos and chatting with sprinkles of information. Fantastic. Anyways, I will link this Reddit post because there's lots of good stuff. I sort of densified everything and added links. CppCast, CppChat, ADSP, Tooth Compliment, TLB Hit, No Diagnostic Required, and C++ Club.
太棒了。我可能会把这句话作为副标题加到网站上。“混乱的闲聊，夹杂着些许知识。太棒了。”不管怎样，我会把这个 Reddit 帖子链接放出来，里面有很多好东西。我把所有内容精简了一下并添加了链接：CppCast、CppChat、ADSP、Tooth Compliment、TLB Hit、No Diagnostic Required 和 C++ Club。
Didn't actually know about that one, although I managed to listen to all 28 episodes in two days. Of course you did. I have a question. Have we actually talked about the K programming language on this podcast before? The K programming language? That's the one that's behind you, right? No, that's Q. I mean, they're tightly related.
其实我之前并不知道那个，尽管我在两天内听完了全部 28 期节目。你当然会。我有个问题。我们以前在这个播客里真的聊过 K 编程语言吗？K 编程语言？就是你身后的那个对吧？不，那是 Q。我的意思是，它们紧密相关。
Have we talked about them before? It's hard to know. In the cinematic universe of my podcasts, I've talked a lot about K and Q, but that's probably mostly been on ArrayCast. Has it been mentioned? I mean, actually, there's an easy way to check this. Well, it might not mean that we haven't mentioned it but if we go to the tags and we go to is there a k there's a j
我们以前聊过它们吗？很难说。在我的播客电影宇宙里，我聊过很多关于 K 和 Q 的内容，但这可能主要都是在 ArrayCast 上。提过吗？我的意思是，实际上，有一个很简单的方法可以查到。嗯，这可能并不意味着我们没有提过它，但如果我们去看标签，然后去看——有没有 K？有一个 J，
but there is no k there's a j and a q on the tags on our website for topics for those of you don't know forget about vow forget about other things that people are doing i I want you to tell me the story of the K and the Q language, because if I recall correctly, this is the programming language that you have often quoted to me as being one that was sold for some ridiculous large sum of money or that, that it was the highest price per like, like the most dollars per byte of program sold or something like that, you said. Yes, you are correct, like 80%.
但没有 K。我们网站主题标签里有 J 和 Q。对于那些不知道的人来说，忘掉 Val，忘掉其他人正在做的事情，我想要你给我讲讲 K 和 Q 语言的故事，因为如果我没记错的话，这就是你经常引用的那个编程语言，据你所说，它曾以某个荒谬的天价售出，或者说，它是每字节售价最高的程序，诸如此类，你是这么说的。是的，你说得对，大概有 80% 对。
Okay. That's about as much as I want to be correct. I don't want to be more right than that because that means I spent too much time researching the thing. I don't ever want to be 80% correct, so tell me more. So this is true. At some point way back, I want to say probably in our first 10 episodes, closing in on 100 here, which is pretty crazy. It doesn't feel like we've recorded 100 episodes.
好的。这差不多就是我希望自己“说对”的极限了。我不想比这更对，因为那意味着我花太多时间去研究这玩意儿了。我可不想有 100% 的把握，所以多跟我讲讲吧。这是真的。很久以前的某个时候，我想大概是在我们的前 10 期节目里吧，现在我们正接近第 100 期了，这真的很疯狂。感觉我们好像还没录到 100 期呢。
But yeah, in our first 10, I think I mentioned at some point that basically Arthur Whitney, the individual behind many, many programming languages, A, A+, K, K1, K2, K3, K4, K5, K6, K7, K9, and Q. Okay, hang on just for a second. All those K languages you just listed, are those evolutions of the same language? No. Okay. All right. all those k languages you just listed are those evolutions of the same language no okay all right can i assume we'll hear more about that later but continue well i can quickly because i had the exact same thought i actually met with the last flight i took before the pandemic was not actually to prague which was in february of 2020. It was to New York at the tail end of February in 2020. And that was to meet with... I can't be upset, Wilsoner, about this trip
但对，在前 10 期里，我想我曾提到过，基本上亚瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）这个人是许多许多编程语言的幕后推手：A、A+、K、K1、K2、K3、K4、K5、K6、K7、K9 和 Q。好的，等一下。你刚才列出的所有 K 语言，它们是同一个语言的演变吗？不。好吧。好吧。你刚才列出的所有 K 语言，它们是同一个语言的演变吗？不。好吧。好吧。我可以假设以后还会听到更多关于这个的内容吧？不过你继续。好吧，我可以快速讲讲，因为我有完全相同的想法。我实际上在疫情前的最后一次航班不是去布拉格——那是 2020 年 2 月。那是 2020 年 2 月底去纽约。那是去见——对于这次旅行，我不能生威尔纳（Wilsoner）的气，
because I did not live in New York at the time. This is true. Very true. But yeah, I flew to sort of meet with Arthur Whitney and got to have a bunch of conversations with him and a dinner with him. And at one point, I didn't even ask a question, but I said something about K's just being like, you know, versions of each other or evolutions. Similar to many other, you know, languages. You could even say C++ with the different versions, etc.
因为我当时不住在纽约。千真万确。真的不能再真了。但是，对，我飞去和亚瑟·惠特尼见面，跟他进行了一堆交谈，还一起吃了晚饭。有一次，我甚至没有提问，只是说 K 语言就像是彼此的版本或者演变。类似于许多其他的语言。你甚至可以说 C++ 有不同的版本，等等。
And he corrected me and said they're not, you know, evolutions of the same. I'm not sure if evolution, I use the word evolution. I'm not sure what he would say to that. But he said they're definitely not versions. It's not like K3 was an upgrade from K2. They are complete rewrites from scratch. Every single time Arthur creates a new language, he deletes, like straight up deletes. You can't go and find the old executables for K5, 6, and 7 unless if you happen to have downloaded it in the past. And maybe you can
他纠正了我，说它们不是同一个东西的演变。我不确定是不是“演变”，我用了“演变”这个词。我不知道他对此会怎么说。但他说它们绝对不是版本。这不像 K3 是从 K2 升级而来的。它们每一次都是从零开始完全重写的。亚瑟每次创造一门新语言时，他都会删除——直接删除。除非你碰巧以前下载过，否则你无法去找到 K5、6 和 7 的旧可执行文件。也许你可以在
find them in the corner of some internet. He just like wipes it off of his computer and then starts from scratch writing a parser, lexer, etc. And admittedly, takes what he, you know, there's the quote that, you know, now that I finished programming this project, I can go back to the beginning and do it the right way because you learn. Okay, but what if you were using the older version of the K language? So there are going to be a number of listeners that listen to both ArrayCast and ADSP that are going to have strong thoughts on this, because this is a question that I've asked the K community literally just within the last month, maybe a month ago, I went to the APL farm, which is a discord that has channels for all the different sort of Iversonian array languages, J BQN, K, uh, Niel. Not sure if I, did I miss them all? APL, BQN, J K and Niel, I think are the five main ones.
互联网的某个角落找到它们。他只是把它们从电脑里抹掉，然后从头开始重新编写解析器、词法分析器等。当然，他会借鉴他——你知道，正如那句名言所说：“既然我完成了这个项目的编程，我就可以回到最初，用正确的方式重新做一遍，因为你学到了经验。”好吧，但如果你使用的是旧版本的 K 语言呢？所以会有许多既听 ArrayCast 又听 ADSP 的听众对此会有强烈的看法，因为这是我最近一个月内向 K 社区问过的一个问题。大概一个月前，我去参加了 APL 农场（APL Farm），那是一个 Discord 服务器，里面有针对各种 Iverson 风格数组语言的频道：J、BQN、K、Nial。我不确定——我是不是漏了一个？APL、BQN、J、K 和 Nial，我觉得是这五个主要的。
And I went to the K, I don't spend much time in the K channel, because it's one of the Ray languages that I know the least about. And I asked, what is, what is like the state of K? Because every time Arthur starts on a new K, he just like deletes everything off his computer and starts a new. And if you're wondering why did they skip K eight? That's because I was wondering that I was about to ask what happened to K. Do you know? Do you have a guess? I know some of our listeners that work. Isn't that like the acronym for like Kubernetes or exactly? Yeah. So they didn't want to, you know, hop, step on the toes of Google, even if it would have been fine, because no one cares. So they and some people say that they kind of wanted to get to K nine, because want to, you know, hop, step on the toes of Google, even if it would have been fine because no one cares.
然后我去了 K 频道——我不怎么去 K 频道，因为这是我最不了解的数组语言之一。我问：K 的现状到底是什么？因为每次亚瑟开始搞一个新的 K，他就会把电脑里的所有东西都删掉，然后重新开始。如果你在想，为什么他们跳过了 K8？那是因为我也在纳闷，我正要问 K 去了哪里。你知道吗？你猜得到吗？我知道我们有些听众在工作。那是不是像 Kubernetes 的缩写或者——完全正确。是的。所以他们不想踩到谷歌的脚趾，即使这样做也没关系，因为没人会在乎。所以他们——有些人说他们有点想直接冲到 K9，因为——不想踩到谷歌的脚趾，即使这样做也没关系，因为没人会在乎。
So they and some people say that they kind of wanted to get to K9 because it's, you know, whatever, cute. But yeah, woof woof. Oh, yeah. Hang on. Hang on. I got it. You continue. I got to get my dog. I'll continue talking. Yes. So every time Arthur starts a K, he starts a new one, which sort of leaves the prior K in a state of limbo. And so it's unclear to me what K is the most popular K or the most widely used, or if someone's going to start learning K, what should they start learning? So the most recent, you might say, oh, the most recent one is obviously the most recent one. But there's always a stage where it's sort of in development. And the current K, K9, has kind of been branded Shakti. And there's been a database in a company.
所以他们——有些人说他们有点想直接冲到 K9，因为——管它呢，挺可爱的。但是，汪，汪。哦，等一下。等一下。我知道了。你继续。我得去叫我的狗。我继续说。是的。所以亚瑟每次开始搞一个新的 K，他都会从头开始，这使得之前的 K 处于一种悬而决定的状态。因此，我不太清楚哪个 K 是最受欢迎或使用最广泛的 K，如果有人想开始学习 K，他们应该从哪一个学起？所以最新版本——你可能会说，“哦，最新版本显然就是最新的那个。”但总有一个阶段它还处于开发中。当前的 K，即 K9，被贴上了 Shakti 的品牌。并且已经成立了一个数据库和一家公司。
Or do you want to have a woof woof break for Looney? Hey, Looney. Can you say K9 again? K9. K9. And that kind of got picked up. Looney and I got to meet in New York. You'll hear about that
或者你想让卢尼（Looney）休息一下，叫几声？嘿，卢尼。你能再叫一声 K9 吗？K9。K9。然后这个名字就火了。我和卢尼在纽约见了面。你会听到相关内容的
in our new york recap episode which apparently we need more more time for in the future but yeah so it's okay nine every k gets abandoned at some point and so of the of the k's in my mind your options are k4 because that's the K that went on to become Q. But the problem is that the company that bought KX, the company, which is the company that owned K4 and Q, doesn't have documentation for K4. And apparently there's some command that you have to turn on in order to enable K4. So K, similar to J j is an ascii based array language so your functions and your operations are single ascii characters um but when first derivatives the company that bought kx bought the company single ask you mean
在我们纽约重聚那一期的节目里——显然我们以后需要留出更多时间来聊这个——但对，所以是 K9，每一个 K 在某个时刻都会被放弃。所以在我的脑海里，你的选择是：K4，因为那是演变成 Q 的 K。但问题是，收购 KX 的公司——也就是拥有 K4 和 Q 的公司——并没有 K4 的文档。显然，你必须开启某个命令才能启用 K4。所以 K，类似于 J——J 是一种基于 ASCII 的数组语言，所以你的函数和操作都是单 ASCII 字符的——但是，当 First Derivatives（收购 KX 的公司）收购这家公司时，单 ASCII 意指
combinations of ascii characters like single i think there are certain digraphs which is two ASCII characters together but most of the functions and operations are single ASCII characters which means I think on one of the Arraycast episodes it was either Stephen Apter or Joel Kaplan said what is Arthur's main motivation for designing. Hang on. I'm sorry. This is, are you allowed to define a function that has a multi-character name? Oh, yes. Correct. Yes. Definitely.
ASCII 字符的组合，比如单个——我想有一些双字符组（digraphs），也就是两个 ASCII 字符连在一起，但大多数函数和操作都是单个 ASCII 字符。这意味着，我想在其中一期 ArrayCast 节目中，无论是斯蒂芬·阿普特（Stephen Apter）还是乔尔·卡普兰（Joel Kaplan）曾说过：亚瑟设计语言的主要动机是什么？等等。抱歉。这是——你被允许定义一个多字符名称的函数吗？哦，是的。没错。是的。绝对可以。
Okay. Yes. Actually, I don't know much about K, so I could be wrong, but like I'm 99% sure that is the case. But all of the built-in functions that come with the language are ASCII characters. That makes more sense. Similar to how all the built-ins in apl are unicode characters okay but to finish my last thought um uh joel or steven whichever one it was said you know arthur's main motivation for designing k and his prior array
好的。是的。其实我对 K 语言了解不多，所以我也许会弄错，但我有 99% 的把握事实就是如此。不过，该语言自带的所有内置函数都是 ASCII 字符。这就说得通了。这类似于 APL 中的所有内置函数都是 Unicode 字符。好了，为了说完我刚才的那个想法，嗯，乔尔或史蒂文，无论是谁说的，你知道的，亚瑟设计 K 以及他以前的数组
languages is the keyboard because it's what is available to you on the keyboard in terms of symbols uh is what you can use anyway so the the point I'm going on a long-winded thing of like, what is the state of K? It's a question I asked, and in my mind, it's K4, the language behind Q. The problem with that is that it's not documented on the KX website where you can learn about Q. Q is very well documented, just not K. And Q is the wordified version.
语言的主要动机是键盘，因为从符号的角度来看，键盘上有什么你就可以用什么。无论如何，我要说的是一个很长的关于 K 的现状是什么的问题？这是我问的一个问题，在我看来，它是 Q 背后的语言 K4。问题在于，在你可以了解 Q 的 KX 网站上并没有它的文档。Q 的文档非常齐全，只是没有 K 的。而且 Q 是将单词化的版本。
So whereas, you know, slash is sort of a reduction in K, the wordified version of that is over. And the backslash, which is a scan, the wordified version of that is scan. Anyway, so instead of ASCII symbols, KX and Arthur put sort of words on it, that became Q. And then for a long time, K7 looked like it was going to be like sort of the k for the end of all times and there was wikis built around that k and there was a big community but then when k7 sort of got ended uh and then k9 showed up the k7 community i think i don't i don't know really what the state of it is so now there's there's k7 which at one point had a big community around it k4 which is behind but a community that ended because this guy unilaterally
所以，你知道的，斜杠在 K 中有点像归约，而它的单词化版本就是 over。反斜杠是扫描，其单词化版本是 scan。无论如何，KX 和亚瑟没有使用 ASCII 符号，而是给它加上了某种单词，这就成了 Q。然后很长一段时间里，K7 看起来就像是那种永恒之末的 K，围绕着那个 K 构建了维基，并且有一个很大的社区。但后来当 K7 某种程度上结束了，然后 K9 出现时，K7 社区，我想，我真的不知道它的现状是什么。所以现在有了 K7，它曾一度拥有一个围绕它的庞大社区；K4，它落后了，但社区却结束了，因为这家伙单方面
decided oh no this thing that you're using i'm gonna delete it and build a better one yes and and so like i'm not i don't think this is an interesting software governance model i don't i don't i don't think arthur listens to this and i if he does or this reaches his ears, I don't want this to come across because I have a huge amount of respect for Arthur. The man is a genius. I have a huge amount of respect for him because you have a huge amount of respect for him. I'm just like, as somebody that comes from a more traditional software community, I just don't like i'm just trying to understand like it's it's it sounds it sounds really out there to me but i'm sure that for folks in the community and for arthur that like there's there's good reasons and probably makes sense it's just like i don't understand
决定：“哦，不，你们正在使用的这个东西，我要删除它并构建一个更好的。”是的，所以我觉得这不是一个有趣的软件治理模型。我不认为亚瑟会听这个，如果他听了或者这传到他的耳朵里，我不想让人觉得我有失尊重，因为我对亚瑟怀有极高的敬意。这位先生是个天才。我对他怀有极高的敬意，因为你也对他怀有极高的敬意。我只是觉得，作为一个来自更传统软件社区的人，我只是在努力理解，听起来对我来说真的很不可思议，但我确信对于社区里的人和亚瑟来说，这是有充分理由的，而且可能讲得通，只是我暂时还不理解
it yet so the reason i was prefacing i have a lot of respect is because I'm about to say something that's kind of critical. It's not for anything you said. It's for what I'm about to say. And that's that I think the biggest problem with the K languages is that that is what Arthur does. He basically starts anew and then you end up with this language that is better than the prior ones. But not only does he sort of delete everything off his computer and then to a certain extent, whether abandon is the right word to use, abandon the community, he also infamously does not like to give interviews and does not like to document sort of the history of things.
所以，我之前说我很尊敬他，是因为我接下来要说一些有点批评意味的话。这不是针对你说的任何话，而是针对我接下来要说的话。那就是，我认为 K 语言最大的问题在于那是亚瑟的做事方式。他基本上是从头开始，然后你最终得到的语言比以前的好。但是，不仅他会把电脑上的所有东西都删掉，而且在某种程度上，无论“抛弃”是不是一个合适的词，抛弃社区，他也出了名地不喜欢接受采访，也不喜欢整理事物的历史。
So there is, I have this, I'll link it in the show notes and I can even read a little bit of it. So we've never get him on the podcast? No, I mean, we I'll link it in the show notes and I can even read a little bit of it. So we've never did him on the podcast? No. I mean, we've asked on a Raycast. I mean, there's a chance that like in the right sort of setup, he might be willing to give an interview. Like I'm not writing it off, but like we've definitely extended the offer. But you haven't explained why.
所以，我有这个，我会在节目文稿中给出链接，我甚至可以读一点。所以我们从来没有请他上过播客？不，我的意思是，我会把链接放在节目文稿里，我甚至可以读一点。所以我们从来没有请他上过播客？没有。我的意思是，我们在 ArrayCast 上问过。我的意思是，在合适的设置下，他可能愿意接受采访。我并没有排除这种可能，但我们确实发出过邀请。但你还没有解释为什么。
Why? If the language is like, yes. Why does he, why does he delete and then start over? I mean, if you gave a lot of people the opportunity to do that with their software projects, there was a ton of people that, given the resources and time,
为什么？如果这门语言就像是，是的。为什么他要删除然后重新开始？我的意思是，如果你给很多人机会用他们的软件项目做这件事，有大量的人，只要有资源和时间，
would definitely say, yes, let's do it. I mean, I think there's always time would definitely say, yes, let's do it. I mean, I think there's always the, the adage of like people underestimate how much work it is to do a rewrite. And so I'm like, I'm sort of put that aside. I realized that it's a ton of work, but like how many people, if you ask them, could, if you had the ability to go back and do it over again, do you think you could do it better? Would that be something you're interested in? Like a ton of folks would say yes to that. And Arthur has the means to do that. Like he's a brilliant, like probably one of the top end developers in the world. He basically does, I think, most of the work on his own.
绝对会说：“是的，让我们这么做吧。”我的意思是，我认为人们总是会低估重构需要多少工作量。所以我会把这放在一边。我意识到这是大量的工作，但是有多少人，如果你问他们，如果你有能力回到过去重来一次，你认为你能做得更好吗？这会是你感兴趣的事情吗？会有成千上万的人对这个问题说“是”。而亚瑟有能力做到这一点。他是个天才，可能是世界上最顶尖的开发者之一。基本上，我认为大部分工作都是他自己完成的。
He's responsible for one of the fastest languages in the world. His company that he sold, he sold for $100 million in two different installments once in 2013 and then fully in 2018. And people like the banks that use Q and KDB Plus, which are sort of the database and wordified version of K that he built, pay a million dollars a year to use the language. And like every, almost every, like when I asked like how many firms on Wall Street use this to someone that I met with in New York he said almost almost everyone like it's it is a it is like the go-to language and so like Arthur built this incredibly powerful tool where performance was the only thing that mattered and people put up with the you know terseness and the fact that it was ASCII symbols and if you put some expression it looks crazy because the people that were purchasing it don't care about programming languages and what it looks like.
他创造了世界上运行最快的语言之一。他出售自己的公司获得了 1.00 亿美元，分两次支付，一次在 2013 年，然后完全在 2018 年。像使用 Q 和 KDB Plus（这是他构建的 K 的数据库和单词化版本）的银行这样的人，每年支付一百万美元来使用该语言。而且每个人，几乎每个人，当我问在纽约见到的某个人华尔街有多少家公司使用这个时，他说几乎每个人，它就像是首选语言。所以亚瑟构建了这个极其强大的工具，在这里性能是唯一重要的事情，人们忍受着它的简练以及它是 ASCII 符号的事实，如果你写出某个表达式，它看起来会很疯狂，因为购买它的那些人并不在乎编程语言以及它看起来是什么样子的。
They care about making money on Wall Street and doing real-time things that need to be done extremely, extremely quickly. Is it statically compiled? It's interpreted. It's interpreted? Yes, which shocks a lot of people. People say interpreted languages can't be fast because when people hear about interpreted languages, they think about Python. But if you write an incredibly, you know, fast, you know, I don't even know what goes into K. You know, I don't want to start saying things.
他们关心的是在华尔街赚钱以及做需要极其极其快速完成的实时事情。它是静态编译的吗？它是解释型的。是解释型的？是的，这让很多人感到震惊。人们说解释型语言不可能快，因为当人们听到解释型语言时，他们会想到 Python。但是如果你编写了一个极其，你知道的，快速的，你知道的，我什至不知道 K 里有什么。你知道的，我不想开始乱说。
Do you know how it's compiled? Is it compiled to a bytecode or what? I think it's just a single sort of executable. It's written in C, very low-level code. I mean, like you say, it's interpreted, but does it compile the language to a bytecode that then gets run through some bytecode interpreter? I do not know, but I don't think this is a bytecode. That's more like something like Python. It's like.pyc files that get left behind are the bytecode compiler. If my understanding is correct, and I'm sure we have a number of listeners that will immediately correct me, feel free to DM me or comment on a Twitter thread or open up a GitHub issue.
你知道它是如何编译的吗？它是编译成字节码还是什么的？我想它只是一个单一的可执行文件。它是用 C 语言编写的，是非常底层代码。我的意思是，就像你说的，它是解释型的，但它是否将语言编译成然后通过某些字节码解释器运行的字节码？我不知道，但这不像是字节码。那更像是 Python 那种东西。就像留在后面的 .pyc 文件是字节码编译器。如果我的理解是正确的，并且我确信我们有很多听众会立即纠正我，欢迎随时私信我或在 Twitter 线程上评论或提出 GitHub Issue。
It's just that each of the primitives have like some specialized code for all the different types. And it's able to recognize quickly if you're operating then dispatch to that statically compiled operation, like previously compiled. So like it is interpreted, but is essentially just ends up invoking specialized, very, very fast code. But I could be wrong about that. Like, I don't, I don't. But that's how the built-ins work. Yes. Okay.
只是每个原语都针对所有不同的类型编写了一些专门的代码。它能够快速识别你是否在进行操作，然后分派到该静态编译的操作，就像以前编译过的一样。所以它是解释型的，但本质上只是最终调用了专门的、非常非常快的代码。但我可能弄错了。我不，我不知道。但内置函数就是这样工作的。是的。好吧。
Anyways. So, so the so why i mean he sold the company for and i think even before he was working on k he did very very well at morgan stanley when he was building a and a plus which were basically predecessors to k and a and they were he those were called apls just basically like ascii versions of um apl which he had learned originally when he worked for IP Sharp and Associates. And yeah, like, so if you go to this history of K page, it says that Arthur Whitney left IP Sharp and Associates in 1992 to create a new language. This was formed, they formed KX Systems. And K2 and K3, K2 and K3 were first commercially developed and supported versions of K made at KX Systems. K3
无论如何。所以，所以为什么，我的意思是，他出售公司的价格是，而且我认为甚至在他致力于 K 语言之前，他在摩根士丹利工作时就做得非常好，当时他正在构建 A 和 A+，它们基本上是 K 和 A 的前身，它们被称为 APL，基本上就是他最初在 IP Sharp and Associates 工作时学到的 APL 的 ASCII 版本。是的，所以如果你去看看这个 K 的历史页面，上面说亚瑟·惠特尼在 1992 年离开了 IP Sharp and Associates 以创造一种新的语言。这就是 KX Systems 的成立。而 K2 和 K3，K2 和 K3 是 KX Systems 制作的 K 的首批商业开发和支持的版本。K3
came with a complete reference manual that consisted of documentation. KDB Plus was a database system that was sold along with K that provided an in-memory database manageable by K. K4 was released in 2000. It actually says 200, so it's missing a zero. In 2003, along with K4, Q was released as a wrapper around k providing readability k4 is the current commercial dialect supported by kx systems which is bundled alongside q k4 requires a command to switch from k to q and the documentation at code.kx.com does not cover k4 and then shakti which interestingly now says K7, K9. It was my understanding that the branding of Shakti didn't come out until K9,
附带了一本由文档组成的完整参考手册。KDB Plus 是一个与 K 一起出售的数据库系统，提供了一个由 K 管理的内存数据库。K4 于 2000 年发布。上面其实写的是 200，所以少了一个零。在 2003 年，与 K4 一起，Q 作为 K 的包装器发布，以提供可读性。K4 是目前由 KX Systems 支持的商业方言，与 Q 捆绑在一起。K4 需要一个命令来从 K 切换到 Q，而 code.kx.com 上的文档不包括 K4。然后是 Shakti，有趣的是现在它写着 K7，K9。据我了解，Shakti 这个品牌直到 K9 时才出现，
but maybe they have retroactively sort of included K7. And it says, Arthur Whitney sold the majority of his stake in KX Systems in 2018 and departed along with a few of his associates to create the new company called Shakti, along with which came the creation and development of the K7 and K9 dialects. K7 was maintained for a few years and is no longer available for use. K9 is currently nascent and, as per on-site claims, supports fast processing of tables with row numbers in the billions and trillions. Binaries for K9 are available at Shakti.com.
但也许他们追溯性地把 K7 包含进去了。上面说，亚瑟·惠特尼在 2018 年出售了他在 KX Systems 的大部分股份，并与他的几位同仁一起离开，创建了一家名为 Shakti 的新公司，随之而来的是 K7 和 K9 方言的创建和开发。K7 维护了几年，现在已经不再使用了。K9 目前处于萌芽状态，根据现场声明，它支持对行数达数十亿和数万亿的表格进行快速处理。K9 的二进制文件可在 Shakti.com 获取。
So, and yeah, when I asked the k channel on the apl discord what's the state of k i got sort of varying answers of i'm learning k6 you can find a bunch of open source implementations of the different k's so there's kona there's ok but these are all just implementations by individuals not the actual executable that was released by Arthur when he was developing it. Because like I said, he deletes them after he's done using them. And yeah, I mean, I find K incredibly,
所以，是的，当我问 APL Discord 上的 k 频道 K 的现状是什么时，我得到了各种各样的回答，比如“我在学习 k6”，你可以找到各种 k 的开源实现，所以有 kona，有 ok，但这些都只是个人的实现，而不是亚瑟在开发时发布的实际可执行文件。因为就像我说的，他在用完之后就把它们删掉了。是的，我的意思是，我觉得 K 极其，
the story of K and Q and R. So these are not open source. So when you say he deletes them, like you mean he deletes like his source and he deletes the binary or he just deletes his source? That is my understanding. And that's what he told me. And that's what he's told many people.
K、Q 和 R 的故事。所以这些不是开源的。所以当你 M 说他删除了它们，你是说他删除了他的源代码和二进制文件，还是他只删除了他的源代码？我是这么理解的。这就是他告诉我的。这也是他告诉许多人的。
Wow. Yeah. Wow. And, yeah, I mean, if you're wondering, sort of, if you listen to a Raycast, you know, why do I like APL? I talk about APL and BQN. Those are probably my two favorite languages. I created this Venn diagram, which I'm sure a few of our listeners that follow me on Twitter have seen, of sort of the delineation between Array languages and Iversonian languages. And then also there's a circle for combinator languages. And K and Q
哇。是的。哇。而且，是的，我的意思是，如果你想知道的话，如果你听过 Raycast，你知道的，我为什么喜欢 APL？我谈论 APL 和 BQN。这些可能是我最喜欢的两门语言。我创建了这个韦恩图，我确信在 Twitter 上关注我的少数听众已经看过了，展示了数组语言和艾弗森语言之间的区别。然后还有一个组合子语言的圈子。而 K 和 Q
don't really have support for combinators. And that's like 50% of what I love about array languages. So in order to do a lot of the things that I can do in APL and BQN, and even JJ has rich support for combinators as well. I can't replicate that code in a Q and Q and K. What, what has made these array languages, this K family, so much more successful than other array languages? Well, so actually, I released...
对组合子并没有真正的支持。这大约占我热爱数组语言的原因的 50%。因此，为了做许多我在 APL 和 BQN 中可以做的事情，甚至 JJ 对组合子也有很丰富的支持，我无法在 Q 和 K 中复制该代码。是什么让这些数组语言，这个 K 家族，比其他数组语言更成功？好吧，其实，我发布了……
So, we're going back. We're hopping in. If you don't listen to ArrayCast, I'm just keep on bringing up things that have been mentioned there. But so there was two meetups that happened, one in Toronto, one in New York. And that was the reason Bryce and I got to meet up was because I was down there for this meetup. And I released the presentation of that, the re-recording on YouTube. And one of the comments I got was, why would you learn Q?
所以，我们回过头来。我们跳进去。如果你不听 ArrayCast，我只是不断提起那里提到过的事情。但当时有两场聚会，一场在多伦多，一场在纽约。这就是布莱斯和我得以见面原因，因为我当时去那里参加这个聚会。我把那次演讲的演示和重新录制的视频发布到了 YouTube 上。我得到的评论之一是：“你为什么要学 Q？”
Because I was including Q in my sort of, it was a comparison of seven different array languages. And I added Q at the last minute for the YouTube recording version and this comment was why are you covering q it's a proprietary language that you need to like hand over your email to use and only then you get like a version that has limited cores you have to limit your cores to like two or four or something like that and uh i said and then i basically linked to this history page and I said, or I linked actually to a GitHub repo that tracks the number of companies that are using array languages. So J, APL, and like K and Q and KDB plus. And I tallied it.
因为我把 Q 包含在我的某种，那是一份对七种不同数组语言的比较中。我在 YouTube 录制版本的最后一分钟加入了 Q，这条评论是：“你为什么要介绍 Q？这是一门专有语言，你需要交出你的电子邮件才能使用，而且只有这样你才能获得一个核心受限的版本，你必须将核心限制在两四个左右，诸如此类。”然后我说，接着我基本上链接到了这个历史页面，我说，或者我实际上链接到了一个跟踪使用数组语言的公司数量的 GitHub 仓库。即 J、APL、以及像 K、Q 和 KDB plus。我统计了一下。
There were 21 using APL and 25 using K, Q or KDB plus. And which is all the same thing. People write it down differently. So four more, then we're listed. And obviously, this is not an exhaustive list. Okay, so I'm going to... Let's just go on the premise that K is successful because from everything I've heard,
有 21 家使用 APL，25 家使用 K、Q 或 KDB plus。这些其实都是同一回事。人们写得不一样。所以多了四个，然后就被列出来了。显然，这不是一个详尽的清单。好吧，所以我要……让我们以 K 成功为前提，因为从我听到的一切来看，
it sounds like it is. Why? Perf. That would be my one word answer. I don't think APL... and to say that people that use apl don't care about perf is i don't think true in all cases that's interesting so that that sort of that sort of means like for me to really understand this i you're the one person i need to talk to somebody who understands how this thing how this thing is so fast
听起来确实如此。为什么？性能。这就是我的一个字的回答。我不认为 APL……而且要说使用 apl 的人不关心性能，我认为这并非在所有情况下都属实。这很有趣，所以这在某种程度上意味着，为了真正理解这一点，你是我需要与之交谈的唯一一个人，一个理解这东西、这东西为什么这么快的人
i mean i'm not sure how many people in the world know how K is so fast because there's only one person that works on the source code and that's Arthur Whitney. Yeah, but no, people must have figured out a bit about how this thing operates. Yeah, maybe. I mean, I'm not sure how many of the wall street folks that are using k
我的意思是，我不确定世界上有多少人知道 K 为什么这么快，因为只有一个在源代码上工作的人，那就是亚瑟·惠特尼。是的，但是不，人们一定已经弄清楚了这东西是如何运作的一些门道。是的，也许吧。我的意思是，我不确定华尔街使用 k 的人中有多少
and q i mean we can get on i met up with the individual that uses k we can invite them on and i mean we're also supposed to have marshall on i said a while ago a lot of people on and we don't always deliver on that um but but i i find find it interesting that if really if the differentiator is performance, my guess would be that it's not just that, it's not just in the implementation. There must be aspects of the K language that make it easier to compile, to interpret efficiently as composed to other languages. I just think that the way it's implemented, it's like the executable is incredibly tiny.
和 q，我的意思是我们可以联系，我遇到了使用 k 的那个人，我们可以邀请他们上节目，我的意思是，我们本来也应该请马歇尔上节目的，我前段时间说过要请很多人上节目，但我们并不总是能兑现这一点。嗯，但但我发现有趣的是，如果真正的差异化因素是性能，我猜这不仅是那样的，不仅是在实现中。K 语言中一定有一些方面使它更容易被高效地编译和解释，与其他语言相比。我只是觉得它的实现方式，就像可执行文件极其微小一样。
I mean, I think it's larger now probably. But what I'm saying is that, no, I'm suggesting that the design of the language, this need for performance has probably influenced the design of the language, this need for performance has probably influenced the design of the language. Like if APL has been around for a long time, if people could make a faster APL, they probably would have, right?
我的意思是，我想它现在可能更大了。但我想说的是，不，我是在暗示这门语言的设计，这种对性能的需求可能影响了这门语言的设计，这种对性能的需求可能影响了这门语言的设计。就像如果 APL 存在了很长时间，如果人们能做出更快的 APL，他们可能会这么做，对吧？
I don't agree with that, no. Why not? I think, so there will be people that disagree with me. I've said this statement to several people. Some people have completely agreed. Other people would say that's not the case at all. So just let it be said that varying opinions on this statement. But originally, APL was not a programming language.
我不同意这一点，不。为什么不？我认为，所以会有人不同意我的观点。我对好几个人说过这句话。有些人完全同意。其他人则会说根本不是这么回事。所以姑且认为对这句话存在不同的意见。但最初，APL 并不是一种编程语言。
It was a notation for teaching. And that's what Ken Iverson, the person that created the notation, it was called Iverson Notation, cared about. He cared about being a tool for teaching. That's why his paper, when he won the Turing Award in 1979,
它是一种用于教学的符号系统。这就是创建该符号系统的肯·艾弗森（Ken Iverson）所关心的，它被称为艾弗森符号系统。他关心的是成为一种教学工具。这就是为什么他在 1979 年获得图灵奖时的论文，
was called Notation as a Tool of Thought. And it's my impression from all the papers that I've read about Ken and his work with education is that he actually didn't care about performance. It doesn't mean he didn't necessarily think it was important at the end of the day, but like when he was designing J and designing APL, he was thinking about how this affects the way people think, not about how fast is this going to run. And because of that, a large
被称为《作为思维工具的符号》。根据我读过的所有关于肯及其教育工作的论文，我的印象是，他其实并不关心性能。这并不意味着他一定认为归根结底性能不重要，但当他在设计 J 和设计 APL 时，他考虑的是这如何影响人们的思考方式，而不是这能运行得多快。正因为如此，很大一部分
percentage of the array language community, when it comes to APL and J don't care about perf. They care about it as a desktop calculator that can do way more than just, you know, integer arithmetic, but can do stuff with, you know, CSV files. And if you need to do something super quickly, it's, you know, a super good quote unquote tool of thought tool. That being said, I think there are people that do care about perf and I think DialogAPL has done an incredible amount of work optimizing idiom recognition and stuff. But to say that someone could just, oh, if someone could create a faster APL, it would have been done. I don't, because I agree, except that it wasn't done, other than maybe, like, the APL that we're talking about is K. Perhaps it wasn't done because of things inherent to the design of the language.
数组语言社区的一部分人在讨论APL和J时，并不在乎性能。他们把它们当作桌面计算器，不仅能做整数算术，还能处理CSV文件等各种任务。如果你需要快速完成某项工作，它就是一个绝佳的所谓思想工具。话虽如此，我认为确实有人在乎性能，而且我认为Dialog APL在优化成语识别等方面做了大量工作。但要说如果有人能创造一个更快的APL，早就做出来了，我不这么认为，因为我赞同这种说法，只是它没被实现——除非我们谈论的APL是K。也许没有实现是因为语言设计本身固有的某些东西。
You're acting as if the language of APL and the language of K are just interchangeable things. And if the design of the language has no impact on performance, the design of the language definitely has impact on performance. The design language definitely has impact and performance. Now, I'm just not qualified to tell you what different design decisions in K versus APL has performance impact because I just don't know enough about those languages. Well, I do know that one of the things that Arthur is famous for saying is there is no operation in the language that's 10 times slower than any other operation. So every operation is within an order of magnitude. Because in the past, there's been attempts to write high-performance APL machines.
你表现得好像APL和K的语言是完全可以互换的，好像语言设计对性能没有影响一样。语言设计对性能绝对有影响，语言设计对性能绝对有影响。现在，我没有资格告诉你K和APL中不同的设计决策对性能有什么影响，因为我对这些语言了解不够。不过我确实知道，亚瑟（Arthur）有一句名言：语言中没有任何一个操作比其他任何操作慢10倍。所以每一个操作都在同一个数量级内。因为在过去，曾有人尝试编写高性能的APL机器。
I'll link it in the show notes if people want to read about it. But they implemented these extremely fast primitives. But when you ran whole programs, the primitives would be really fast, but you'd spend 99% of your time in these operations that weren't weren't critical how does apl differ from k well the the number one thing is one's unicode one's ascii but you can kind of ignore that yeah the second thing is that my and i'm sort of once again people can correct me i'm not a kid and for the record i don't think that the the uh the choice of unicode some symbols for uh apl syntax i do not believe that has any any real impact on the uh the speed with which you can interpret the program um probably not
如果人们想了解它，我会在节目介绍中给出链接。但他们实现了这些极其快速的原语。然而当你运行整个程序时，原语本身确实很快，但你99%的时间都花在了那些不关键的操作上。APL与K有何不同？好吧，最主要的一点是一个用Unicode，一个用ASCII，但你基本上可以忽略这一点。是的。第二点是，我认为——再次声明，大家可以纠正我，我不是K程序员，而且郑重声明，我不认为为APL语法选择Unicode符号会对解释程序的速递产生任何真正的实质性影响……可能没有吧。
but in in line with what i said earlier about ken it does impact the tool of thought which is why i bring it up because it's much harder for an ASCII symbol to be visually representative or numomic. How do you pronounce that? Of the operation than it is for a Unicode symbol that's like tailored. The second thing is that K and Q don't have true higher dimensional arrays, and they also don't have a rank operator. They do have the concept of rank, but I think the primary data structure is an array. But also second to that is something called a table, I believe, or dictionary. I'm going to mess up what it's actually called, but it's more of a hash map of vectors where each of the values is a vector that doesn't necessarily have to have the same length.
但正如我刚才所说，它确实对思想工具产生了影响，这也是我提起它的原因，因为ASCII符号很难在视觉上具有代表性或助记性。那个词怎么发音来着？比起量身定制的Unicode符号，ASCII很难做到对操作有良好的代表性。第二点是，K和Q没有真正的高维数组，它们也没有秩运算符。它们确实有秩的概念，但我认为主要的数据结构是数组。不过排在第二位的好像叫表（table），或者是字典。我可能会把它的实际名称记混，但它更像是一个向量的哈希映射，其中每个值不一定具有相同的长度。
And so you do a lot more with hash maps than you do in other array languages, because hash maps don't exist in other array languages. So things like querying and the database. So that's the other thing is KDB+. The K language and Q language come with an incredibly powerful database. And I think it specifically has like a ton of functionality for time series stuff, which obviously if you're on wall street is stuff you want to do. And there is a database that comes with J called JD, I believe, which is kind of supposed to be in the similar vein is what
因此，你用哈希映射做的事情比在其他数组语言中要多得多，因为哈希映射在其他数组语言中并不存在。比如查询和数据库。这就是另一回事了，也就是KDB+。K语言和Q语言附带了一个极其强大的数据库。而且我认为它专门针对时间序列数据拥有大量功能，显然如果你在华尔街工作，这些都是你想做的事情。J语言也附带了一个数据库，好像叫JD，据说它的路线和KDB+类似。
KDB plus does. But yeah, in APL, there are databases, flip DB, stuff like that, but like nothing that was built, like tailor-made for high-frequency Wall Street stuff. So the existence of dictionaries, and also, too, I've talked to a few people, Michael Higginson, who just won the APL professional tier of the APL contest, and another individual. And these folks have been telling me how I need you know, I need to learn more about KNQ so I can speak because there's a bunch of stuff. Like I think one of the things that Michael mentioned,
不过是的，在APL中也有数据库，比如flip DB之类的，但没有一个是专门为高频华尔街业务量身定制的。因此字典的存在，而且我也和一些人聊过，比如刚刚赢得APL竞赛APL专业组冠军的迈克尔·希金森（Michael Higginson），还有另一个人。这些人一直在告诉我，我需要——你知道的，我需要更多地了解K和Q，这样我才能发言，因为里面有很多东西。比如迈克尔提到的其中一点是，
and I apologize, Michael, if I'm going to get this wrong, but he mentioned that you can have, well, so actually this is something I know for a fact that I didn't get from Michael's, that most of the functions in J, APL, BQN are limited to sort of two arguments, unary function and binary function. And when you want to have multiple arguments,
如果我记错了的话，迈克尔，向你道歉。但他提到你可以拥有——实际上这是我百分之百确定不是从迈克尔那里听来的事实——J、APL、BQN中的大多数函数都局限于大约两个参数，即一元函数和二元函数。而当你想要有多个参数时，
I believe the idiomatic thing is to sort of chain them into a list of things and then destructure them. So really you've got unary and binary. Whereas in K, you can have any arity functions. They've got a syntax for basically a function and then it's defined by braces. And then at the front of it, you put in brackets
我认为符合地道习惯的做法是将它们串联成一个列表，然后进行解构。所以实际上你只有一元和二元。而在K中，你可以拥有任意元数的函数。它们有一种语法，基本上是一个函数，然后通过大括号来定义。在它的最前面，你输入方括号，
and then you just separate with semicolons all of your arguments. So if you want to have a function with five arguments, you just go A, B, C, D, E. And you can do basically, and this is the thing that Michael told me, he says you can, I can't remember if it's called like modifying the valence, but if you basically want to do partial application to any of the arguments. So similar in C++ when we have, you know, bind front or bind last or before we had those two, we had bind. You had those like underscore one, underscore two to place the placeholders for the variables that you would want to take from the return function. There's a super convenient syntax for that where basically you can do partial application for it. So if you
然后用分号将你的所有参数隔开。所以如果你想拥有一个有五个参数的函数，你只需输入A、B、C、D、E。基本上你可以做到——这也是迈克尔告诉我的，他说你可以，我记不清这叫不叫修改化合价（valence），但如果你基本上想对任何参数进行偏应用（partial application）。类似于C++中我们有bind front或bind last，或者在我们拥有这两个之前，我们有bind。你有那些诸如_1、_2之类的占位符，用来放置你想要从返回函数中获取的变量。有一个超级方便的语法，基本上你可以为它进行偏应用。所以如果你
have a five argument function and you want to turn that into a three argument function with the first, third, and fifth arguments, that's super simple to do. You basically just like fill them in and you have first class functions. That's another thing that KNQ have, whereas APL and J don't. They have first class functions. Wait, APL doesn't have first class functions? No. It has defunds, which are similar to lambdas a bit of an odd i mean you got to remember apl was created in 1960 well first implementation was in 1966
有一个五元函数，你想把它变成一个只包含第一、第三和第五个参数的三元函数，这做起来超级简单。你基本上只需填入它们，并且你拥有了一等函数（first-class functions）。这是K和Q拥有的另一个特性，而APL和J则没有。它们拥有一等函数。等等，APL没有一等函数？没有。它有defunds，类似于lambda，有点奇怪——我的意思是，你得记住APL创建于1960年——好吧，第一个实现是在1966年——
and bqn the newest iversonian apl language does have first class functions and is much more functional in a number of ways. Yeah. We should either have some of the Q folks that I've talked to, we should bring on Michael, or I should go, I'm thinking, so here's, I was going to tease this on a Raycast, but maybe I'll just say it here. I mean, I was going to, but then I left it out, but I'm thinking about,
而BQNs——最新的伊弗森（Iverson）系APL语言——确实拥有一等函数，并且在许多方面更加函数式。是的。我们应该要么邀请我聊过的那些Q语言专家中的几位，把迈克尔请来，或者我去——我在想，所以，这里是这样的，我本来打算在一个Raycast节目里卖个关子，但也许我直接在这里说吧。我的意思是，我本来打算说的，但后来我漏掉了，不过我在考虑，
because we've been sort of on a break, my programming language is a virtual meetup for the last couple months since July. And I'm thinking about the next book, just being a dictator and choosing it, usually there's a vote, and making it Q for Mortals, which is a book that's on the KX website for learning Q. And once I get through that book, I'll be much more informed well i know how the implementation and why the language is so fast i'm not sure but yeah we're at like the i don't know 30 minute mark the brisket is was at 166 when i last chucked which was about
因为自从七月份以来，我们的编程语言虚拟聚会已经暂停了几个月。我正在考虑下一本书，直接独裁式地选定它——通常会进行投票——将其定为《Q for Mortals》，这是一本在KX网站上用于学习Q的书。一旦我读完了那本书，我就会对——好吧，我知道它的实现方式以及为什么这个语言如此之快，我不太确定，但无论如何——我们正处于大约30分钟的标记，我上次检查时牛胸肉是166度，大约是两分钟前。
two minutes ago you got until the brisket's at about 180 and then I really got to watch it. Well, I mean, what else do you want to know about K slash Q? I mean, we basically kind of covered it. ASCII language, dictionaries. Okay, but you said you created some other languages. Oh, yeah. Well, I mentioned A, A+. That was when he was at Morgan Stanley. He left...
你得等到牛胸肉达到180度左右，然后我就真的得盯着它了。好吧，我的意思是，关于K和Q你还想知道什么？我的意思是，我们基本上已经讲过了。ASCII语言，字典。好吧，但你说你创造了其他语言。哦，对。嗯，我提到了A、A+。那是他在摩根士丹利的时候。他离开了……
Well, actually, it says on this history page that Whitney left IP Sharpen Associates in 1992. I thought he left IP Sharpen Associates to go to Morgan Stanley. And then he worked at Morgan Stanley for a year. And then I thought actually maybe he even worked at another bank before he started KX. But regardless, he worked at a couple banks at some point, worked at IP Sharpen Associates. And when he was at the banks is when I thought he was working on A and A+.
好吧，实际上这篇历史页面上说惠特尼（Whitney）在1992年离开了IP Sharpen Associates。我以为他离开IP Sharpen Associates是为了去摩根士丹利。然后他在摩根士丹利工作了一年。接着我甚至以为他在创立KX之前可能还在另一家银行工作过。但无论如何，他在某个时候在几家银行工作过，曾在IP Sharpen Associates工作过。而当他在银行工作时，我认为他正在开发A和A+。
He also wrote a language called B, which is actually open source and online. I'll find a link to it, throw it in the show notes. And you'll get a taste for the style of C code, which is very similar to the way that J is programmed, which is open source, which is very, very macro heavy. I think when I was working on the J source code, trying to port it to C++, I measured and there was like 10,000 macros. So they, and they, it's not like,
他还写了一种名为B的语言，这实际上是开源并在线提供的。我会找到它的链接，扔到节目介绍里。你将会领略到C代码的风格，这与J语言的编程方式非常相似——J是开源的，并且非常非常多地使用宏。我想当我正在处理J的源码、试图将其移植到C++时，我统计了一下，大约有一万个宏。所以它们，而且它们不是那种，
oh, macros, the way we use them in C, like they create macros for everything. And then you program in macros, basically, like for a dyadic or a monadic function, AKA a unary function or a binary function, they have V1 and V2. And that's how you define a function that has one or two variables.
哦，宏，就像我们在C语言中使用它们那样，它们为一切都创建宏。然后你基本上就是用宏来编程，比如对于一元或二元函数，它们有V1和V2。这就是你定义一个带有一个或两个变量的函数的方式。
For four loops, they've got everything. So everything is a macro. And I think that's similar to how Arthur Whitney has designed his... And famously, there's something called the incannabulum, which is actually a word that means a book before it's a book or something. And it's called the J incannabulum. And Ken Iverson wanted Arthur Whitney to work on J with him
对于for循环，它们什么都有。所以一切都是宏。我想这类似于亚瑟·惠特尼设计他的……而且著名的是，有一个叫incannabulum的东西，这其实是一个词，意味着一本书在成为书之前的手稿或者类似的东西。它被称为J incannabulum。肯·伊弗森（Ken Iverson）想让亚瑟·惠特尼和他一起开发J，
when basically Ken decided we're done with APL. We're done with Unicode symbols. We've tried for three decades. Unfortunately, they didn't wait for like five more years when like unicode became a thing and so they switched to i do not think that unicode becoming the thing would have substantially improved the likelihood of apl seeing widespread adoption you know we'll never know but the point is is that it's a lot the state of unicode support in software in general in 2022 that's because you're a c++ programmer does no it's not a c++ specific problem the state of unicode support
当时肯基本上决定我们受够了APL。我们受够了Unicode符号。我们已经尝试了三十年。不幸的是，他们没有再等上大约五年，等到Unicode真正普及开来，所以他们转向了……我不认为Unicode的普及会实质性地提高APL获得广泛采用的可能性。你知道，我们永远不会知道，但重点是，2022年软件中对Unicode支持的现状整体而言——那是因为你是个C++程序员——不，这不是一个C++特有的问题，Unicode支持的现状
just across software in general does not lead me to believe that the world even today is ready for a language that leans so heavily on unicode uh yeah i mean it's a fair take it's a fair take um but yeah so when ken was starting work on his new language j aka apl 2.0 and even there's a presentation i'm not sure if it's recorded and online but i definitely know the slide deck is something and i believe it it's called APL question mark or something. And it's this presentation of this new, quote unquote, it was called an APL at the time, but just not with Unicode symbols. And he was presenting it at an APL conference.
在整个软件领域中，并不让我觉得即使在今天，这个世界也已经准备好迎接一门如此严重依赖Unicode的语言。呃，是的，我的意思是这是一个合理的观点，这是一个合理的观点。但是，当肯开始着手开发他的新语言J（即APL 2.0）时，甚至有一个演讲——我不确定它是否被录制并在网上发布，但我绝对知道幻灯片是存在的，而且我相信它被称为《APL问号》或其他什么。这是关于这个新的，所谓的——当时被称为APL，只是没有Unicode符号——的演讲，他在一个APL会议上展示了它。
And kind of everyone was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, you're calling this an APL? This isn't an APL. You know, to the guy who invented the whole thing. Anyways, he went to Ken, or sorry, he went to Arthur to ask him to work on it. Arthur said, no, I've got my own plans, aka A plus, you know, K. And, or at that point, maybe he had already done A and A plus, and he was about to go on to K. But he went to this farm, and there's a Wikipedia page that explains this whole thing. And so even though he was telling Ken, no, he said, I'll get get you started and he wrote this single page of j
然后基本上每个人都觉得，哇，哇，哇，你管这叫APL？这根本不是APL。（这话是对发明了这一切的人说的。）不管怎样，他去找肯，或者抱歉，他去找亚瑟请他一起来开发。亚瑟说，不，我有我自己的计划，也就是A+、K。或者在那时，也许他已经完成了A和A+，正准备转向K。但他去了这个农场，有一个维基百科页面解释了整个事情。所以尽管他对肯说不，但他还是说，我来帮你起个头，他写了单页的J
code and um that was basically the start of the j programming language and it's called the j incannabulum i believe as i pronounce it um why um okay so he created a a plus b and why did go to k like like oh like what's the name? Yes, alphabetically. Like, why? So A was clearly short just for A+. And Array Language loves their single-letter stuff.
代码，这基本上就是J编程语言的开始，它被称为J incannabulum，我是这么发音的。为什么——好吧，所以他创造了A、A+、B，为什么会变成K？就像，名字是怎么来的？是的，按字母顺序。比如，为什么？所以A很明显是A+的简称。而数组语言非常喜欢它们的单字母命名。
So APL was just a single-letter version of APL. And then... Sorry, A is a single-letter of APL. A+, is because they added a gui to a so a plus is just a with a gui b follows pretty clearly yeah but then c was taken okay what about d uh not taken at that time i don't think d was taken at the time what about e yeah i don't i don't know about that but so i think at that time j actually i don't know about that. But so I think at that time, Jay, actually, I don't know if Kay got named first or Jay after. But the reason Jay was chosen was because when they were starting on the language and doing work, Roger Hui, the main implementer on it, was told to, like, get started or whatever.
所以APL只是APL的单字母版本。然后……抱歉，A是APL的单字母。A+是因为他们在A的基础上添加了一个图形用户界面（GUI），所以A+只是带GUI的A。B的出现也很明显，紧随其后。但接着C被占用了。好吧，那D呢？那时还没被占用，我不觉得当时D被占用了。那E呢？是的，我不太清楚那个。但所以我觉得当时J——其实我不知道，我不知道是K先命名还是J后命名。但之所以选择J，是因为当他们开始着手开发这门语言并进行工作时，负责主要实现的罗杰·惠伊（Roger Hui）被告知要开始工作之类的。
And so he just named the file. If you look at your keyboard, if you're sitting in front of a computer right now which probably none of you are what letter on your keyboard has a little thing that you put your index finger next finger is resting so it was just the easiest letter to type so he just saved his file is like j.c and then that's what the name of the language became why K I actually don't know I don't think you know cake oh. The array programming language historian. A rare falter. All right.
所以他只是给文件命名。如果你看着你的键盘，如果你现在正坐在电脑前——可能你们没有一个人在坐在电脑前——你键盘上的哪个键旁边有一个小凸起，可以让你的食指放在上面？所以它只是最容易打的字母，于是他把文件保存为j.c，然后这就成了该语言的名字。为什么叫K？我其实不知道，我不认为你知道，凯。哦。数组编程语言历史学家。难得卡壳。好吧。
You look that up. I'm going to check on the brisket. We are getting there. 171.3. This is great. Great podcast content. I was going to say, I'm on the KAPLwiki.com page, and it says, this does not answer the question,
你去查一下那个。我去看看牛胸肉。我们快到了。171.3度。这太棒了。绝佳的播客内容。我正想说，我在kaplwiki.com页面上看到，上面写着，这并没有回答这个问题，
but I just learned something. K7, the first Shakti K, was the first K to have full Unicode support. Oh, then not in terms of Unicode characters. So he sold, he creates his company. Chris's company? Who's Chris? No, he creates this company. he sells company who's chris no he creates this company oh creates okay then he sell then it becomes you know big and popular then he sells it
但我刚刚学到了一点。K7，第一个Shakti K，是第一个全面支持Unicode的K。哦，所以不是指Unicode字符。所以他卖掉了——他创建了他的公司。克里斯的公司？谁是克里斯？不，他创建了他的公司。他卖掉了公司——谁是克里斯？不，他创建了他的公司——哦，创建了，好吧，然后他卖掉了——然后它变得，你知道的，又大又受欢迎，然后他卖掉了它，
then he goes off and keeps making new k languages yes correct i think he collected 40 million in 2013. Were the people who bought this company from him perhaps not thrilled about this? Oh, yeah, probably not. Probably not. I mean, I have not talked to anyone directly at first derivatives about how do you feel about Arthur continuing to do exactly what he was doing before? But I would imagine that they would have probably been happier if he had just retired. Also, too, someone corrected me when I was in New York, said that, you know, it's not Arthur didn't own 100 percent of the company. So he didn't. And he sold the company for 100 million.
然后他离开并继续制作新的K语言。是的，没错。我想他在2013年拿到了4000万美元。买下这家公司的那些人可能对这一点不太高兴吧？哦，是的，可能不太高兴。可能吧。我的意思是，我没有直接与第一衍生品公司（First Derivatives）的任何人谈过，问他们对于亚瑟继续做他以前一直在做的事情有什么感觉。但我猜，如果他当时直接退休了，他们可能会更高兴。另外，我在纽约时也有人纠正我，说这并不是说亚瑟拥有公司100%的股份。所以他没有。而且他是以1亿美元的价格卖掉公司的。
But there was obviously other shareholders and stuff. So he he got a percentage of 100 million, which I said, you know, does that matter? Like $40 million, $100 million? Those two are the same number to me. And he was like, you're clearly not from New York, all right, you know? Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但显然还有其他股东什么的。所以他拿到了1亿美元中的一部分百分比，我当时说，你知道，这重要吗？4000万美元、1亿美元？对我和说这两个数字是一样的。然后他就像是在说，你显然不是从纽约来的，好吗？感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝有个美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。